is nothing to be fun it's housing fans
need it amazing does anyone have just
cause why these two should not be
married speak now or forever hold your
peace looking ahead to next season and
fingers crossed if we do get iris out of
that mirror world yeah you and I have
chatted about this many times before
what are the chances on that west-allen
fowl renewal since we all agreed their
wedding was a little bit yeah different
thing yes and I pronounce you wait wait
wait just one second um I don't know
that's actually not something we've
discussed but I could see it making
sense in us needing it especially now
after finishing this whole mirror
storyline and us being so separated and
yeah that would be probably a cool thing
to see actually once that this is all
this story is all resolved
all right grant I'm gonna be chatting
with Candace next do you have a question
for her yeah well considering this beer
our wedding was spoiled on a cross over
of Supergirl sure and we had a pipe
let's say a shotgun wedding on an
episode of legends of tomorrow so
terrible would she be interested in
renewing our vows on flash not our vows
Barry and iris espouse obviously because
I think it'd be fun that sounds like
fans need it that's a great point which
is something I will say something I
would love to see before we in the show
whenever that is I think a lot of fans
were disappointed with the how Barry and
iris ended up getting married and I
think that's a fair fair thing to be
kind of peeved about so yes grant I
agree I think we should revisit that at
some point I think we should get the
fans what they want I think we all were
a little bit like how do I get married
on another show when you buy the DVDs in
the flash in the future you're never
gonna see their - getting married for
real so I think it's only right that
before we wrap up the show Barry and
iris get married on their own show so
for posterity flash fans
in every question yes stick with me I'm
thinking that could be next year's
crossover where there's nothing wrong
it's just everyone having fun at the
reception that's a good idea as long as
we keep it on the flash that it needs to
happen on the flash I'm Supergirl yeah
yeah I'm game if it happens on the flash
amazing you and Candice have been
starring opposite each other since the
pilot you know I've seen their love
story grow what has it been like for you
guys to act the season where it's not
the iris that we've known and loved this
whole time it's slightly different did
that change the dynamic between you guys
at all
yeah I mean I think a lot of that
closeness has been missing this year
there haven't been as affectionate
towards each other and we could
attribute that to a lot of distress that
was there for the team and for Barry and
but then you see it when we finally find
out it hasn't been you know Irish this
whole time it makes even more sense but
this just been a completely different
mostly it's that we've seen a lot less
of each other on set we've just been
wearing weird very weird because the
iron.i playing for so long so
compassionate so she cares so much for
other people she will do whatever it
takes to take care of other people to
save the city to save other people and
so to play this very selfish
manipulative maniacal version of iris
was different and to play the opposite
Barry he was so also loving and
compassionate and empathetic to other
people it was just weird that the scene
that we had in a loft where she
eventually you know tells him to leave
and that he only makes decisions for
himself it was just a very thing for me
Candice to play because I had to play
that very often with Grant and I
remember having a very difficult time
getting through that scene and really
kind of feel real because we just don't
do that often and then we had that scene
at 6:17 where we're like one of the most
emotional scenes we've both had all
season and it's to a mirror we were both
like not they're on the same we shot
those different days so we weren't even
there at the same time when we shot that
so it's really weird but I watched that
up
actually and I thought it was hard not
having him there for sure
it made it doubly difficult for me this
whole season working with mirrors
shooting into a mirror where you're
looking at yourself and you're also
seeing like all of the crew behind you
in some way and just having to shoot
that scene with very looking at myself
and not him completely distracting like
one of the hardest scenes I've ever shot
on a show he shot it so many times it so
many takes it was really difficult and
really distracting but I I was pleased
to hear that people really resonated
with that scene and felt emotional about
that scene so I'm just happy that it
came through we've got something that
that um worked it looked gorgeous and it
was so emotional and fingers crossed if
we get iris out of that mirror world we
will be getting a lot more happy moments
between them next year yeah I think we
all are ready for that ya know it's it's
been a different season I know people
are missing that dynamic and we'll get
it back I'm sure
[Music]